[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by
the one and only Ken Coleman this hour
and we're taking your calls at AAA
825-5225 and I know you all got
questions because I got a lot of DMS Ken
from people who are confused there's so
much noise there's so many distractions
they're scared they're at a Crossroads
they need some confirmation they need a
third party opinion and we want to be
that for you today whether it's around
money career or just your life and Ken's
gonna bring that wisdom for you also if
you got some work questions you're
worried about your work situation maybe
you want to leave but you're scared
financially let's walk through that work
in money those are tied together and
it's what I love to talk about with
George and uh if they're looking for uh
third party opinions they have come to
the right third and the fourth we do we
we have the opinions we're here for you
so nice uh nice uh uh uh denim combo
your shirt matches the thread on your
denim jacket and I noticed that and they
say men don't notice I noticed that's
amazing looking sharp today we're here
for you we'll give you fashion advice
while we're at it triple eight eight two
five five two two five Lauren kicks us
off in Fort Wayne Indiana Lauren welcome
to the show
I
am how's it going
say my question first
um I uh I'm trying to figure out how to
work together with my spouse in
budgeting and doing bills and stuff when
they struggle with not being great at
finances and not being great at paying
bills and stuff and so I just wanted
some encouragement on how to work
together with my spouse or when like I'm
the nerd and he's the free spirit and
trying to figure that out ah I like it
so uh is it safe to assume that you are
great at the details and great at paying
bills
I'm good at it but I my health sometimes
makes it really challenging to keep up
with everything oh what's going on
I am I have like autoimmune disease and
stuff and I also deal with like regular
sicknesses and I'm pregnant oh wow
goodness
so it's it's a wild time at your house
yeah and in the middle of all this
you're going we got to get our finances
in order
yeah yeah
appreciates it he he he does appreciate
it and tries to help he's just not great
at it and and uh he works a lot so
George I I I'm hearing this and I'm
wondering if automation is not her
friend you know meaning the automated
get the the get when she's feeling well
get to a point where we pay where things
are coming out Auto draft or things of
that nature to try to spare him from
having to pay
does it feel overwhelming to him is it
he wants to spend okay set up on
everything I possibly can my biggest
struggle is
um getting I I get lots of new bills so
I like feel like every month there's
always a new bill and always something
that needs to be set up on payment plans
and something needs to be uploaded to
our insurance and so I get overwhelmed
because I'll just fall behind on those
things and I ask him to help me but he I
don't know if it's just because he's
never good at planning much with
anything let alone bills and so when I
ask him to help me for something you'll
a month or two will go by and he'll have
not touched it yet and then eventually
I'll have to do it myself once I find it
yeah this is beyond just a financial
issue this is communication and this is
his commitment to y'all's marriage and
y'all's future and that's a that's an
even tougher thing to manage because we
can get through the financial part and
get him to go here's why the value of a
budget I think this is beyond that you
need to let him know how scared you are
how this is affecting you and saying I
am underwater right now I'm struggling
with my health I'm pregnant there's a
lot going on with work I need to feel
like this is a team and right now it
feels like I'm on my own on this little
island yeah have you said that to him I
feel like I've started doing that yeah I
I I asked him also for like just
counseling for like community and stuff
like just working on being able to
communicate better because I'm learning
that our family differences and stuff
and how we grew up is definitely
affecting our understanding to towards
each other so yeah that's huge what is
his familiarity with kind of our Ramsey
plan
he's pretty familiar we've never gone
through your actually program I grew up
as a baby Ramsey a Dave Ramsey baby but
my parents still struggled with it a
little bit but I when I got older and
once I realized that money wasn't going
great because I I saw my Mom struggle
with money and I figured I didn't want
to do that so I just kind of left
everything to him for a few years and
then realized he was struggling a lot
with it but this is this year and last
year the first year I've actually like
tried to like do everything and so
um I I'm struggling to keep up with
everything I know I'm better than him
and he's he's very familiar with Dan
Ramsey and I think he like he may not be
like I would say he's like 99 Dave
Ramsey but there's this little bit of
stuff I don't know the guy doesn't even
want to talk about a budget so I have 99
feels very generous talk with me about a
budget he just won't do it him like he
won't help me make the budget and he'll
follow the budget but he won't help but
if you say hey I need your help
uploading this bill to insurance and he
disappears for a month or two that tells
me he's not that committed to this plan
right and to you as not as a husband but
as far as a partnership goes in getting
through this wild season you guys are in
so what are you doing to budget right
now are you using every dollar or a
different tool yes I'm using every
dollar okay so when he looks at every
dollar and you go here's the plan he's
the free spirit so when he shows up to
that budget committee meeting are you
letting him have a say
I'm totally letting him have a say but
usually he just looks and he's like
let's go got it okay and does he follow
it you said he does does he follow it
but he I mean he primarily doesn't make
any of the purchases that like so okay
so he so he's not our farm expensive
separate from our life expenses and I
primarily make all the purchases for our
life expenses so he's not he's not going
outside of the budget he just is
literally hands off on any financial
transaction other than him getting gas
in the car on his way home
yeah well he does he
he just purchases
his very like he doesn't make a budget
for the farm expenses he just knows I
need to feed this day I need this this
day and he does it anyways I gotta tell
you something I I don't think this is a
I mean first of all some people are more
detailed and organized than others and
then I get that and I teach this all the
time play to your strengths and and get
somebody else involved on your team if
if you've got a giant area of weakness
in your relationship same thing you know
play to your strengths and if your
spouse is strong where you're weak let
it go and work together here's what I
think is going on I don't think this is
about strengths and can't excuse me and
and can't I think it's he doesn't want
to I think he's got some some real fear
something emotional in him that he just
doesn't want to deal with the finances
he doesn't even want to touch it it's
like hey I
I got this bill that came in
can you pay this I think he's just he's
got some real emotional challenge with
money yeah well I hope this helps Lauren
I'm going to gift you with one year of
Financial Peace University have him
watch just the first lesson Rachel
breaks down budgeting and hopefully it
encourages him along the plan and every
dollar as well and I would ask him
here's my point in there I I want to
make sure you two do some some marriage
counseling and get to the point let a
therapist really work on that fear why
does he delay two or three months on
just you saying hey I need you to pay
these three bills yeah I think that's
going to help you too tremendously and
the communication that you want to get
better will happen as a result of that I
think marriage counseling is the next
step yeah this is just beyond this
normal budgeting stuff so hang on the
line Austin will gift you one year of
every dollar premium and Financial Peace
University I hope it helps thanks for
the call
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
one guarantee and being is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your work your money all the things that
matter to you now listen we have people
who tune in to every episode of the
Ramsay show we have data that proves
that and they know all the stuff we
teach about money and they still feel
stressed out and stuck why because
knowing what to do with your money isn't
the problem actually doing it is and we
know that personal finance is 80
Behavior 20 head knowledge and a proven
way to change your behavior with money
is by taking a Financial Peace
University class that is what doing it
looks like so this class is the
difference between trying to get into
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer you're gonna have a
coordinator that's holding you
accountable and other people in the
class pushing you and cheering you on
and that's why these classes work for
Millions you need that Community you
need that accountability and after nine
weeks you will never handle money the
same way again you will make progress
faster than ever so don't just listen to
us commit to doing what it takes to win
you can join an FPU class at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com slash FPU
I'm leading my class tonight George oh
that's that's right you're on the
evening schedule got the Wednesday
Friday nights for the wild and crazy
phone how's it going I've been enjoying
mine if you didn't know Ken and I are
both leading a class right now I believe
it's too late to join Ken's you might
still be able to sneak in how'd your
first one go you just started it
wonderful you were nervous the other day
you you almost threw up on your desk
it's a lot of pressure when a few
hundred people are going I need this guy
to help me but it was an honor of a
lifetime and we have fun a great time
it's a lot of fun a lot of fun whether
it's virtual or you can do one in person
in your community it is so worth it and
it goes Way Beyond you know just what a
book or podcast could do for you it's a
Next Level commitment and it is so worth
it all right let's get to the lines Ally
joins us up next in Portland Maine Ally
welcome to the show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
how can Ken and I help
so my husband and I are currently in
baby step two working on paying down our
debt um and we're just wondering if we
should sell our house to help with
paying our debt and rent for a while wow
okay how much debt do you have
um total we have 450
000 in debt that's including our
mortgage which is oh 214 of that oh you
scared me half to death okay so how much
is the Consumer Debt let's focus on that
okay it's 234 a thousand okay and what
is your income
uh 120 000 a year good and what kind of
debt is this 234 what's it made up of
it's kind of it's a little bit of
everything
um some credit card debt some medical
debt and
um student loans and then we do have a
home equity loan oof and a car what's
the car worth
um the car is worth 31 000. and what's
left on those 43 on it oh did you roll
negative equity into it yes oh you guys
have done it no we didn't real negative
equity into that but um it's just gone
down and you're sure of this you've
checked like the private party value on
Kelly Blue Book
yeah that's the the 31 is the Kelly Blue
Book
ouch
okay so we've got it we've got a mess on
our hands you guys are willing to do
something about it to the point that
you're going should we sell the house
yeah yeah what's the equity in the home
we could
um we probably could get right about 400
000 on the house that's what it would
sell for
yeah and how much California what would
your net profit be after all the fees
and all that
would probably be around 350.
but the house isn't paid for you still
got a mortgage on it yeah so once the
mortgage is paid and the fees are paid
what would you make
we would it would be like 80 000 that we
could put onto our debt so we still have
quite a bit of debt okay that was my
question because this is not gonna it's
not a get out of jail free card to sell
the house but it will speed this process
up
yeah what would be your plan let's
assume that you didn't ask us and you
guys had already done this what would
your living arrangements be
um
we were planning on
for rent if we sold
renting obviously is hard right now
um
but that would kind of be where we're at
just to put more money down on our debt
what is your mortgage payment currently
versus your take-home pay monthly
um our monthly take home and say well
we're kind of like really gazelle
intense right now so we're making about
10 grand take-home pay great
um and
um our mortgage payment is fifteen
hundred okay it's a good payment
so here's I would say before you go sell
the house I would see how much traction
we could make to increase our income
okay I don't think it's worth selling
the car at this point uh with your
income you have another car that's paid
off or is this the only car
yeah we have another car that's paid off
okay
so unless you could you go down to one
car for a while or you need two cars in
the house
um we've been contemplating that we we
could go to one car for a while okay and
then how much do you have in savings or
non-retirement Investments
we just have our hundred dollars in our
uh I mean a thousand dollars in our
um like our baby step one okay
so here's the question for me have a
baby Zoe oh fun
adding to the party we paid off our
medical bills from that mm
started our snowball cool so if I was in
your shoes which is how we answer
questions on the show I want to see
before we make this huge step of selling
the home can we build enough traction
get enough extra income which Ken can
help with in order to knock this debt
out faster because if this is going to
be a five-year debt payoff process we've
got to speed it up and selling the home
is probably the right move but if you
can go all right we're gonna take our
income from 120 to 180 and we're going
to throw 100 at this debt and it's gone
in two plus years then I go great yeah
because the problem is your your
mortgage is 1500 you might have to go
rent for 2500. right more than yeah
exactly and so it doesn't necessarily
solve all your problems uh at this point
and so I want you to keep your home
until you realize there's no light at
the end of the tunnel we got to sell
this thing so it's a last-ditch effort
but what are the ways you're increasing
income now
because there's a lot of overtime and
then I've been making
um quite a bit in bonuses
um right now I'm on maternity leave so
but it will be going back soon
um so if that will increase it a little
bit too
um
but that's basically what we've just
been doing is trying to pick up over
time when we can and you're and you're
probably limited that's probably your
best option is overtime versus other
side gigs you're going to just get more
for your for your time correct
right yeah yeah I would look really I
would look hard I would look everywhere
I wouldn't accept the first couple of
options you know
um I remember it feels like a year or so
ago we had a lady come in and do her
debt free scream and she was a travel
nurse and she just went crazy working
traveling uh from covet on and was able
to make an enormous amount of money so I
think George is right you guys need to
have the same gazelle intensity about
making money right now as you do about
saving and paying off debt how far up
these or how far where is the uh the car
uh that you owe 40 on uh where's that in
the debt snowball
um it's almost at the end it's at the
end it's our second to last step yeah
okay all right we have a lot of little
debts okay well I kind of like that
because I I wanna I'm with George I
wouldn't sell the house yet
okay uh but I will tell you I have a
slight I don't know if there's a
difference of an opinion but to me if
you guys is this your Forever house is
this a house that you let's just say
that you had no debt right now would
this be the house you want to stay in
long term
yeah that's the thing is it won't be
we're definitely gonna outgrow it all
right I would look at the budget
and I would I would look at it and I
would say okay yes our our rent's gonna
go up but if we could take 80 000 let's
assume that's the number that you could
put towards debt right now I would go
right through the snowball and I'd take
eighty thousand the first 80 and then I
would say how much more money a month
now are we going to essentially have
control over there we're not paying
towards debt and I would look at that
with the new budget I'm going to put
that towards the rest of the snowball
but now I'm increasing my cost over here
on this line item and I would look at
that yeah and if you can keep that
income nice and high at 10 grand or more
take home then it's doable I'd actually
probably sell it I really would George
to to get the momentum of 80 000 to get
us out of this process and know that now
we're going to start fresh emergency
fund 3A then 3B if you will and that's
what I would do I'd actually sell it
knowing I don't want to be there long
term I love it well if you can make the
budget talk it over with your spouse and
see what makes sense for you guys but
either way you are you have the
intensity to do this thing and we want
to help we're going to gift you one year
of Financial Peace University to cheer
you along call us back when you're debt
free we can't wait to hear the story
thanks for the call
[Music]
thank you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
we're going to take a break from our
regularly scheduled programming of
taking calls to take a live call and
it's not just a call it's a debt free
scream on the stage with our newest
friends Muhammad and Catherine how are
you guys good doing great where are you
guys from Fort Worth Texas oh wonderful
you guys are so in unison you've got
matching t-shirts I just love this one
let's uh before we go any further for
our listening audience Reed tell us
what's on the T-shirt I'm not sure I can
make it all out it says how could I make
sense when I got millions on my mind
since being NTS yes that I gotta tell
you uh we've had a lot of debt-free
screamers with the theme t-shirts I'm
nominating you guys all time best
I'm going to go ahead and put to that
nomination forward we'll put it to James
and see what happens all right Ken's got
a lot of pull around here so how much
debt have you guys paid off
three hundred and thirteen thousand
three hundred thirty nine dollars wow
shut the front door that's amazing and
how long did that take three years eight
months wow a lot of Threes a lot of
Threes yeah how long and what was your
range of income during this time we went
from 110 000 to about
175. tell me how
um well I'm a nurse
um so the pandemic was rough on a lot of
people and it was also rough in the
Healthcare Community but that was an
opportunity for me to get in there work
a lot of extra hours I worked multiple
jobs at the same time for a large part
of this and
we just got it done and also too so I
work in law enforcement and during
covert time me and her we just took
advantage of it
um yeah and I don't I'm gonna share it's
a lot more light on her than it is me
but she was working two jobs uh two
nursing jobs while she was pregnant oh
my God she was working on Covert floors
wow and so she she really she busted her
butt during covert time and she was
working more hours than me she was
embarrassing me when it comes to working
over it was not embarrassing I just
could make a little bit more money
that's incredible you guys are our
definition of power couple yes what kind
of for how you serve sir thank you yes
thank you what kind of debt was this uh
over 300 Grand student loans and our
house payment oh my goodness paid off
the mortgage yes house and everything we
are looking at some weird that explains
the Millions on their mind yes wow
they're on that track okay so three
years and eight months ago you guys were
staring down the barrel of 300
some Grand what made you go we're gonna
get rid of the student loans and keep
barreling through this house well you
know what I think at first when it
started uh when they uh paused the
student loans and was like hey this is
this is our time this is our time to go
for it 100 and so
once we you know we got past the student
loans and I was like yeah hey you know
what I'm satisfied I'm grateful that we
paid off our student loans but let's
just knock out all of our debt let's
continue to be
um intense and also um intentional
intentional at the same time and she was
on board she said hey let's get done and
you know once we wrote the numbers down
on papers like hey you know what we can
do this we can sacrifice a little bit
more time to be done forever wow so you
just you were like an object that's
that's in motion stays in motion let's
just keep this party going yes she says
I have tunnel vision a lot and I wanted
to be debt free so let's be debt free
all the way because
um I knew once we start this New Journey
of being debt free I wouldn't
um I don't want to pause again I don't
want to say hey let's knock this out
let's just do it all at one time well
now you believe it you've already got
the hope the numbers are right there
it's just like well mathematically
here's what we need to do yes and I kept
asking like hey Ken are you okay can we
do this for a couple two more years and
and here you are yes initially like it
was going to be a little longer and then
I was just like I'll be honest it was it
was hard on me I was like
this is tough you know I see how much
money we make and how much money we're
spending per se like our budget was very
very very very tight and so
yeah I was you're making 175 and feeling
broke because all the money's going
right back out yes and and she's tired
and Pregnant two nursing jobs and
growing a baby I mean that's
unbelievable what was the mindset that
you took on when you were feeling like
uh I don't have to do this I'm exhausted
what did you do to keep going
um well I'll prefer a second initially I
was not on board with the baby steps
with sure all of this I knew that I
always wanted to like be out of debt
like I understood Financial like my
parents kind of taught that to me
growing up but I didn't necessarily like
know how and so he discovered Dave a lot
sooner than I did and he would listen
and say all of this stuff and just going
on and on and on and that we only need a
thousand dollars I was like a thousand
dollars in this savings like that is
ridiculous like what is that sounds
insane I'm just gonna be honest how I
was originally feeling and um
it seems like after he stopped
pressuring me I think that gave God room
to really work on me and and let me see
what was going on and then one day I
just happened to be listening to Dave
and we're like okay I think we can do
this and actually I just came to him and
I was like I think we should empty out
our savings down to a thousand and just
go there and then this was they tell in
a 2019 and so then when the pandemic hit
um
I kind of just seemed like okay the
cares act came out they said the student
loans will be paused until October
let's do it like we can get this done by
October of 2020. that was my goal so
when everyone else is laying back you
leaned in you're like all right
absolutely yeah wow you guys are
incredible how did you get connected all
this stuff was there any tools or
resources or podcast how did you find us
honestly
um it was on vacation we were on our way
vacationing somewhere and I was on
YouTube looking out how to become a
millionaire how to get debt free and
like I want to Vacation all the time how
do we get there and
um the Ramsey uh Dave Ramsey uh uh
podcast was showing up on YouTube and I
was like oh my gosh like this dude is
crazy this is this is me like this is
how this is what I want and it was like
uh thank you God because now I know I'm
not crazy I know I'm not the only person
that thinks that you know thinks that
doing it like this can work and so when
I found him it was like look this is my
thought process and look somebody
Believes In Me who's already a
millionaire and there's hundreds of
people who has already done his babies
steps that have said this works and
it was like a match made in there wow
and you're on your way now are you guys
net worth millionaires yet you've got to
be close not yet but we are owners
yes that's incredible how does it feel
now to be completely debt free you guys
did this thing it was amazing I would be
honest it didn't really like feel real
initially because I was still working
two jobs at that point but that first
month when like our mortgage didn't come
out it was like oh this is amazing
it's a slow Burn yeah but no it felt
like amazing like you said we got a pay
raise but now we're investing our
retirement more and we're able to at
least for me
um I have the option if I wanted to and
have more kids to even stay at home and
that's something that wouldn't be
afforded to us if
we did not go through and make this
journey
um yes and for me
um honestly it feels great because I
kept telling her like it's times where
you know I can tell she's not happy
because you know she wants to get her
feet done or get her eyelashes done more
and I'll always tell her hey you know
I don't want to settle with you for the
minimum I want to give you the maximum
in life oh that's beautiful and you know
this is something that I truly wanted to
do and it's because I have you know my
um people who are inspire me like my
uncle and even my father-in-law her uh
pops you know they have shown me a great
path of saying hey this is you know not
telling me but showing me hey you know
when you're changing your family tree
now yes let's get your little one up
here before we run out of time what's
the name and age this is Titan oh love
it okay he is 22 months and um
his first step free scream here we go we
got a living give box for you with
Financial Peace University baby steps
millionaires Total Money Makeover pass
it on to someone you love to get them
started it's Muhammad and Catherine and
Titan Fort Worth Texas 313 Grand paid
off three years eight months making 110
to 175. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
oh
house and everything family tree changed
Legacy initiated that's how it's done
folks this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour
new listener and we know that we got a
lot of people who are just finding us
through Google and YouTube and Spotify
and TBN and who knows where I want to
let you know you can dive deeper into
all the stuff we're talking about today
to the Ramsay baby steps into the lingo
that we were preaching out on here you
can go to ramseysolutions.com and click
on the get started button and we will
help you figure out the next best step
for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today that's
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
Mackenzie joins us up next in Concord
New Hampshire Mackenzie welcome to the
show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
so I have about 335
000 in debt and that includes my house
my student loans and my car
um my mom also took out a couple Parent
Plus loans for me when I was in college
which were about twenty thousand dollars
and she I think she's kind of expecting
me to give her money for that
um all of the different
um that has different interest rates and
I have some money saved I just want to
know like the best way to start paying
that back cool and what's your income
about sixty thousand okay and how much
is the Consumer Debt that you have if
you subtract the mortgage from that 335
the student loans are
um 52 000 in my name and my car is 7
500.
okay cool and you make 60. and uh you
got 20 that is kind of you're you're not
sure but you're going hey Mom's wanting
this paid back even though legally it's
on her you kind of feel the obligation
to pay her for this
okay and how much do you have in savings
about thirteen thousand oh nice
okay what's your current life situation
you're out of school you're working
full-time
yeah I'm working full-time I have a
part-time job as well um and my
boyfriend and I own our house together
so it's not just me on that oh is are
both of your names on the deed
yep and the mortgage
yes okay how does that work out what
happens if you guys split
I don't think that'll be a problem
why so sure stranger things have
happened I'm just saying I know I've
I've started talking to people I know
but
um
we're we're very sure before we
we do want to get the debt paid off
before my debt paid off before we get
married so is she helping pay your debt
off
um no but
um
kind of like he's going to but I want to
I want to kind of work on that does he
have that
no okay I would keep your finances
completely separate including separate
bank accounts do you guys have a joint
bank account or are they separate
we have a joint bank account for the
house oh boy
okay well I'm gonna try to answer your
question because that's what you called
in for how can I get rid of this debt
and the crazy part is I'm going to tell
you to ignore the interest rates
okay the best way I found this is what I
did I had student loans I had credit
cards I had 40 grand total in Consumer
Debt and I just listed them out from
smallest to largest balance and I just
ignored the interest rate because this
is about Behavior right now and not
about math and once you do that you
follow the debt snowball method will you
make minimum payments on all the debts
but that littlest one we're going to
attack with a Vengeance with that
part-time job with selling stuff rice
and beans budget cutting out the
subscriptions cutting out eating out and
you will attack that debt pretty quickly
making 60 with what how much do you have
total on that
7 500 and then another 52. yep okay
that's cooking
so in two years this thing should be
gone can you throw 30 000 at it a year
with your extra part-time job
probably not because our house payment
is expensive
oh gush how much is it
500 a month okay and you guys are
splitting that
yeah okay so it's 12.50 a piece
yeah so it's not crazy once you once
it's all split up but it's still a lot
yeah that includes taxes and everything
sure
okay well I mean this is beyond the debt
snowball which you can do and I would
suggest doing it on your own I don't
want him paying this off because and
again this is the show people call when
everything didn't go to plan
when everything on paper didn't work out
and so that's why I'm telling you I
don't want him paying off your debts all
of a sudden something doesn't work out
and he goes well I paid off your debt I
need that money back and it becomes a
huge issue
right and are you going to pay mom back
too have you talked about this and what
we're going to do there
for it um like some because there was
more than that a few years ago and then
with the payment paused
um I was focusing on my own stuff that
I've been still paying through the
um covid
um interest rate cards
um
and
so I thought I was in my name too and
like I've been recently doing my
research and I see now that like it's
not so I don't know what to do okay
I would probably roll that into your
debt snowball and make that a part of
the plan because this is going to it
will ruin the relationship if you just
leave this hanging out there and it's
probably already causing some resentment
for Mom
yeah well there's bigger issues there
but I feel like she won't be paying
anything on it
um in the meantime like I feel like
that's what we're worried about it this
thing's improving interest it's in her
name right it's hurting her financial
life she's going to be unable to retire
with this thing hanging over her neck
student loans you can't bankrupt and so
this thing's not going away and so we've
got to communicate about a plan don't
let Mom just sit there wondering what's
gonna happen Okay I I
you guys have got to get this this
marriage situation figured out you're
what I heard you say was is that you
wanted to wait to get married to pay off
this debt and you guys have got No
Boundaries that you should actually have
because you're not married and so I
don't know why you guys don't just get
married and and and do this thing
together I just am so concerned about
what could happen here and I know you
don't believe anything could happen but
uh I'm gonna tell you something there's
no guarantees here and you're in a very
unstable situation and I I don't want to
be unkind and that is not my heart here
it's to say that if you guys are
committed to marrying each other and
staying married I wouldn't wait let's go
ahead and get married join together as a
team and and remove these weird
relationship Dynamics where we should
have boundaries we don't and and then I
just I don't know what you're waiting on
I think that like trying to put all of
our money we can towards debt it's like
well we don't want to it costs money to
get married and like we're not like we'd
have like a really expensive wedding or
anything like that but why don't we like
use our money now to
pay off the debt rather than spend it on
a wedding okay I appreciate that thought
I've got a comeback for you you go down
to the courthouse this evening and get
that done it costs nothing you can do a
ceremony later I can't tell you how many
couples did that during covid and did
their celebration later uh yeah so
you're making excuses here and listen
I'm not getting on you I just think this
is a powder keg that could blow up on
you and there's so much going on here
and George I and again I'm not telling
you what's morally right and morally
wrong I'm just saying from a
relationship standpoint what we know
about the data and marriage and money
um this thing is really weird and I
don't know why I would wait I would I
would get married let's do a celebration
and ceremony later and and let's move
forward with our lives together not
separate on some things together on
others I mean I just I don't I don't
like it it's just I think it's going to
set you up for defeat yeah it makes me
nervous just hearing about all you've
got issues all over Mackenzie so it's
beyond just get
simplify your life
relationally and financially is what I'm
I'm begging you to do
okay
we wish you the best Mackenzie I don't
know if you'll do any of this but we we
gave you the truth and that's the most
we can do on this show but we've just
seen it for every McKenzie there's
another call who went I had a house with
my boyfriend and we thought it was going
to work out perfectly and it didn't and
we had no Financial protections and it's
so messy because I'm on the mortgage and
he's not and who pays now and it just
breaks so hard to hear those stories
anytime you've got a ton of complexity
in any area of your life
get to Simplicity as quickly as possible
because when it's complex you got all
these pieces that are kind of balancing
or kind of not bumping into each other
all it takes is one thing to just go
wrong and the whole thing Falls and
that's what I'm concerned about there
well and we got Mom and so parents out
there please do not take out Parent Plus
loans for your kids thinking that it's a
blessing the interest rates are insane
you're on the hook and it puts your kid
in a weird position do not do this
please find another way for your kid to
go to school debt free don't take the
bait those Parent Plus Loans are toxic
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books my thanks to Ken Coleman my
co-host all the dudes in the booth
keeping the show float today and you
America thank you so much for tuning in
we'll be back before you know it
[Music]
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by best-selling author
Ken Coleman this hour it's a free call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five you've got that lingering
question you're just not sure you're
tired of just Googling and hoping we
hope to give you some good advice on
this show whether it's about your money
your work life or something else in
between we're just maybe some
relationship advice Ken's got a lot of
wisdom in that Arena that's for sure I
I've been married a long time I will say
this I uh I don't ask for it but I do
enjoy the occasional uh dating
relationship advice situation because I
like to get right down to brass tacks
he's seen it all folks oh boy I haven't
I so if you tell you what I'm seeing
more of that that we want to talk about
here because it affects our listeners
and viewers pocketbooks what's that I'm
gonna tell you what it is I've got a
I've coined a phrase George I've coined
a phrase for it okay you know what it's
called what's that the compensation tax
oh let me tell you what this looks like
you show up to a coffee shop in my
neighborhood the other day I order
myself a Cuban to go
nice choice by the way I'm getting ready
to pay
what happens
the young man behind the counter with a
little bit of entitlement I might add
as I'm paying flips the screen around
I'm ready to pay flips it around and
says uh
here's where you're paying tip sir
and I think to myself
now it's expected that I tip I'm tipping
it I'm tipping at restaurants which is
normal now we're tipping everywhere
everywhere you go everywhere you go
there's an iPad involved there's an iPad
you got a tip option I just say no thank
you to the iPad I go don't turn that
around I don't want to know it's your
business I didn't get that
confrontational I just went with the I
paid and I didn't do it I didn't do a
tip and I'm gonna tell you what it is
these small business people business
people in general are getting smart and
you got inflation happening to them in
the form of they're having to pay higher
wages you know what they're doing
they're adding a compensation tax
for us that's what I'm calling it and
our little tip helps them
juice the hourly wage yeah I don't have
to give them a raise if I can just get
the customers to give more tips but see
there was no email there was no sign on
the door that explained this just one
day you started getting prompted to tip
where you didn't tip before yes so if
you're not serving me taking my order uh
multiple trips for multiple drinks I'm
not tipping you if I'm standing up and
you're asking me for a tip it's over
this better be a sit down lay down
situation if you're wanting a tip from
me you know yeah the barber shop the
massage the restaurant if I'm standing
I'm doing the work right now right you
know what I mean you know I appreciate
it I won't stand for this okay oh thank
you you put your foot down you went full
Seinfeld there there you go but let me
know did you say this though this is a
thing and I'm just pointing it out you
and I agree it's okay to not tip in that
situation yes not a restaurant a waiter
situation but just it's a transaction
across the counter now if you want a tip
fine but but don't throw the hate at
George and I because we don't feel like
we got a tip in that situation I won't
stand for it and I actually this is
funny you mentioned this I just released
a video on my new YouTube Channel about
when you should and shouldn't tip and I
made it very clear okay lay it out for
us my stands for it did we cover
everything I give I gave you a taste
this is a tease to go watch the video oh
you don't want to give it away but a
follower on Instagram just sent me this
Ken and I think you'll appreciate oh
yeah the guys have a picture of this if
you don't put this up on the screen for
those that are watching this is a sign
that's at the register at a Jet's Pizza
somewhere in America I do like by the
way some Jets I really do I'm gonna read
it to you Ken tips are no longer
accepted thank you to all of our
extraordinarily generous customers we
are here because of you rest assured in
lieu of tips we are increasing the
compensation of all our team members we
look forward to continuing to provide
the best possible customer service thank
you from your Jet's Pizza team now
that's good leadership it's good
leadership now I'm assuming this is
referring to uh pickup uh and takeout
sure yeah if they're delivering pizza
you should be you should be tipping I
want to stipulate okay good but if
you're picking up the pizza and then
they spin around the iPad I don't want
to deal with it I drove move all the way
here to pick up the pizza so I didn't
have to pay the delivery fee until I
like it George I like it so there you go
that's the move I think more business
owners need to do put the sign out there
and say not only are they not expected
but they're not even accepted yeah and
by the way this is this has fundamental
economic impact here when you start
talking about putting an extra tip on
where where customers aren't used to
tipping that's real inflation to them
and you're trying to do it you're
socking it to your customer
Because Of You the wages you want to pay
or maybe you're trying to juice your
profits and I think there's going to be
a lot of Snapback on this Kickback
there's I understand and that's why the
sign is existing Jets is seeing a
competitive Advantage for taking that
position so there you go and I would
want to give my business to those kinds
of business owners who are doing those
things and this is not you know people
come at us can they go wow I can't
believe these guys are so stingy they
don't want to be generous this has
nothing to do with generosity absolutely
be generous whenever you can in all
situations it's this idea of I'm going
to socially have a socially awkward
moment where I spin around the iPad and
the employees don't want to do that
either they always go it's got a
question for you I don't know what the
question is there if they feel awkward
too and hey while we're on this subject
folks when you go out to eat at a
restaurant check the bill
because a lot of restaurants are socking
in an extra fee that has nothing to do
with taxes state and local taxes and I'm
one that I'll have the manager come out
and go talk to him about this what is
this what is this this this this thing
you've stuck here on the bill that's not
tax related and it's not the tip line
watch out for it look at your bill
you'll see it yeah I have them out there
going you didn't tell me about this when
I walked in that's a good point check
your receipts and it's okay to ask and
say hey I got billed for this I don't
know what it is that happened to me at a
restaurant and it said health tax help
and I was like who whose Health my
health yeah I found out we are
subsidizing the health care for the
employees for the business owners don't
have to yeah I don't think that's fair
let me tell you what I don't have to do
folks I do not have to pay a tax
that some politician didn't pass so you
can put it on the bill but unless unless
Congress or state and local government
passed it
take this tax and shut up Kenny boys you
know what I'm saying there you go just
just crumple that little receipt normal
way to do a new one is you raise prices
and if the customer no longer wants to
pay those prices they'll do business
elsewhere and that is the that is the
obligation and the right of any business
person go for it let's see if it works
but don't hit me with the old guilt trip
tip oh boy yes and Rachel Cruz and I we
did an episode we called it guilt
tipping I thought you'd like the pun
there on Smart money happy like cow
tipping yes but very similar yeah I like
that but no cows are hurt young people
watching the show right now have no idea
what cow tipping is well I'm pretty sure
anyone that doesn't live in Middle
America doesn't know what cow tipping is
yeah I don't know what that is you know
have you never heard of it I've heard of
it I would never do it
you know I'm not going full Peta here
I'm just saying I don't think it's a
nice thing to do yeah I'm not taking a
position on it I've never attempted it
for the record so spare the hate mail
sounds like it might be hilarious I feel
like the cow would it would kick back
and it would be over which is why it
would be funny I think I lose trying to
do that they love that comedy yeah well
if you want to learn more about this uh
I made it hopefully very entertaining
video you did on my YouTube channel
called when you should and shouldn't tip
and you can just search for George
Campbell with a K on YouTube and let me
know your thoughts drop some comments in
there and tell me when you think you
should and shouldn't tip because
honestly it's exhausting trying to
figure it out because you don't want to
be a bad person you don't want to be
socially judged we want to be generous
but it's gone too far it has thank you
for that Ken
from our mouth to your ears that is our
thoughts on tipping whether you want it
or not we've hit the Tipping Point on
tipping I think we're exhausted from
talking about tipping at this point I
might tip you just to stop talking about
it oh my goodness this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsay and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
listen paying off debt is smart saving
and investing very smart but there is
one key to winning with money that
people Overlook all the time and that is
protecting your finances from
emergencies and that is exactly the role
of insurance now there are 10 kinds of
coverage that you might need based on
what your life looks like today and to
make it easy on you our team has built
an incredible tool called the coverage
checkup to show you which types you need
to add drop or adjust we'll even rank
your coverage list by importance we'll
email it to you and connect you with a
Ramsay trusted insurance provider so you
can get your plan in place fast
seriously this could be the most
important five minutes you spend today
you can do that at ramseysolutions.com
checkup that's ramseysolutions.com
checkup and Ken let me read you a
message I just got on Facebook yesterday
from a fella he said you saved me 650
dollars for the next year by shopping
insurances home and auto thanks sir wish
I checked that a few years ago I
couldn't have planned it any better and
now I didn't do anything he said you
saved me I didn't do anything he did the
work but it takes actually doing this
checkup to go yeah do I have the right
coverage
so if you're looking to make more money
uh you don't have to always go do the
side hustle sometimes you can just
reshop your insurance and then get a
better rate you sound so true love it go
check that out all right let's go to the
phones uh is it Sheila in Seattle Sheila
welcome to the show
hi thank you guys absolutely
thank you so much for this opportunity
so um I'm going to give you a quick
background eyeliners I work from home
near Seattle and I started my MBA
um to help me move up uh my company has
been paying for it and they have paid uh
so far seven thousand and
um my commitment to them is is
um to look for a job three months after
I complete my MBA and this should be
done around between January to March uh
because I'm about to be done towards the
end of the year however
just last week I learned that I'm going
to lose my job uh several of us uh well
five of us are losing it and throughout
the company
so I have the option to stay here as a
nurse and not probably less desirable
position so I can continue to make money
and also to keep my commitment uh that
7000 is actually through the Union
so
um so Sheila I'm sorry Sheila I'm sorry
I'm going to interrupt because I'm
confused
um okay you said you're losing your job
but then you have the opportunity to
stay there so you're losing your current
nursing job but they're offering you a
another nursing job that doesn't pay as
well okay yes and so it'll be about the
same pay but it as I'm looking
internally
you know uh they're not the very
desirable jobs
um they're okay jobs and they're
probably our hybrid I don't want to be
back to a clinic nursing job or you know
urgent care okay um I love I lost all of
that experience anyway
um so
um so I do have the option to go outside
within my company but I will lose you
know I'll have to pay them back the
seven thousand so my question is should
I just get anything I could and stay
here until spring or you know through
the end of 2024 yeah so hold on so your
commitment so you don't want to pay back
the 7 000 and so you your your
commitment is I didn't understand that
part your commitment is you stay through
the spring and then what are you able to
do
employer but if you don't stay until the
spring you're gonna have to pay them
Seven Grand back immediately yes
yes okay uh I I I think and you want and
you want and you'll be done with the NBA
as well at this time yeah I will be done
with my MBA my goal is to be done by
this this fall okay and so what why the
NBA do you want to stay in nursing or
was this your exit out of the nursing
industry oh well both ways if I
if I get into
Tech and this industry
to do sales or something business
I'll have to stick it out with nursing
in a management role which
um is is all right no it's not it's all
right no it's not it's not it's okay to
say I don't want to be a nurse it's okay
for you to go I don't want to be a nurse
so if I understand this right I'm sorry
I'm trying to pay attention to all the
variables I don't think any of the
variables really matter that much
because you don't want to be in nursing
long term
and quite frankly the MBA you're going
to finish this fall anyway and the NBA
has nothing to do with you getting into
Tech sales
it just doesn't you know if you can yeah
and so Tech sales is a very very good
industry to be in it's got a lot of
opportunity so if it were me I would
stay in the nursing role because it's
gonna even though the one you're in now
you're you're not going to be able to be
in but you can get another nursing role
that pays about if not the same money
pretty close to it if I heard you right
and I don't have it's actually going to
be the same money okay probably perfect
yeah but we don't have to pay seven
thousand dollars back I personally would
stick it out to next spring and not have
to Fork out seven thousand dollars
because okay you've done it before you
can do it it's not the end of the world
is it desirable no but you don't want to
be in nursing long term anyway and I
think it allows you time to start
looking today and let's see if we can
land a great gig if there's any other
qualifications like maybe a
certification or something like that to
be able to sell for a tech company there
might be some training if this gives you
time
uh to find the path to find another
opportunity and and so I I would stick
it out and and not pay the seven
thousand George do you disagree with no
I'm with Ken unless you just are flush
with cash you have no debt and you just
you can get an opportunity soon in that
world and make the same money then I
would stick it out until then so do you
have any debt so
no I don't
um I through the Dave Ramsey program
I've been really blessed incredibly I
have my emergency fund I I got a condo
I'm even paying extra thousand dollars a
month my kid has just graduated from his
um business ad degree I am not anxious
about my job loss while the other nurses
are anxious and so I I could really just
afford to let go of the seven thousand
but seven thousand is still seven
thousand you agreed and that's why
unless you're gonna go hey I'm going to
get a ten thousand dollar pay bump and
I'll just pay the Seven Grand and be
done with it and it's not in my
emergency fund because it's not an
emergency then in that case I'd go all
right if you find a great opportunity
you don't want to stick this out for 10
more months go for it I agree with that
I would stick around right now until you
find that opportunity yeah let's say you
find something really great this fall
and the increase in pay is there and you
can you can actually afford the Seven
Grand we don't by the way this is not an
emergency fund situation this is Seven
Grand above and beyond everything you're
doing uh then of course you can do it
you know but if you can stick it out and
time it out right that'd be awesome
absolutely well Ken this brings up the
point that a lot of people face in their
careers and in their work of kind of the
golden handcuffs yeah and that's where
she finds herself of going I want to
leave but I'm stuck because of XYZ and
if I leave I'm gonna owe them this and
it's one of the reasons some of these
benefits I'm not a huge fan of because
you go I got to work for this employer
for three more years and what if I want
to leave nursing what if it's toxic
that's exactly right and it's not to say
that her decision is wrong or
anyone hasn't been able to use this type
of situation in their benefit but most
of the time when companies pay for your
education or reimburse you they're
looking for a commitment and to me it's
it's it's about Freedom I'm going to
keep coming back to this you know at the
heart of everything we teach through the
seven baby steps what we call Financial
Peace is freedom when Dave says if you
live and give like no one else if you
live like no one else later you can live
and give like no one else what is at the
core of that statement it's freedom I
have options and not only do I have
options I and only me get to choose
what option I'm going to take and so I
think it's very important to say should
I be patient
and cash flow my way for additional
education
is that the better move or should I take
money
from a company
and be okay being a bit of an indentured
servant here where you know essentially
they paid for this now I owe them x
amount of years and I think
I I think that's a tough decision for a
lot of people because they're thinking
about the money they're going to spend
but I would rather spend my money and
have freedom on the other side yeah I
was just watching Financial Peace
University with Dave's debt lesson and
he says when your boss starts yelling at
you and you start walking away and say
where are you going I don't have any
payments it's so true that's the kind of
Freedom we're talking about when you
follow this path money work it's all
connected more of your calls coming up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour this is the Ramsay
show and we're here for you this is a
show about you and for you to help you
take the right Next Step In Your Money
life in your work life and whatever else
is going on the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Christian is up next in Fresno Christian
what's up
are you with this Christian
yeah yeah thanks for taking my calls Ken
George thank you absolutely
hey so um quick uh I'll just give you a
quick background so I make about
um eight thousand dollars a year uh I'm
on baby step two right now currently uh
just kind of started about a month ago
um I have about 64 000 in that uh give
or take a thousand bucks but um and
about 20 000 of those are in credit
cards and Loans which that I'm not too
worried about that I feel like I pick
out within you know Max six months the
rest of it though about forty three
thousand dollars of that debt is in a
vehicle and um I guess I was just
calling to ask you guys opinion whether
or not uh I should just keep it or is
you know downgrade because uh if I keep
it technically uh I should in theory be
able to pay it off
um within two years uh best case
scenario if not uh uh maybe add another
five months to it
um or if I should just uh downgrade the
problem with that is that um I'd be
taking an uh you know I'm negative on it
so I'd be taking that loan with me about
it it would be about like 10 grand that
I'd be taking with me uh even if I would
so what's the car worth
it so the car is worth about 35 from all
the websites I've gone in and I owe
about 43. okay so what's stopping you
from going to a credit union and taking
out a loan for the difference and being
done with this thing and being eight
grand in debt instead of 43 Grand in
debt
because that's what I was asking because
of a new I'd have to go and I'd work
about 30 minutes away so I'd still have
to get a decently card that could take
me there I'm not talking about anything
expensive just sure uh it seems like a
lot of uh a lot of headaches you know
how much money do you have in the bank
uh like you mean like right now yeah
between your checking and savings all
that
um
probably uh combined with the emergency
fund probably uh three grand maybe okay
and how quickly could you save up
another five grand
it wouldn't take too long about uh in
about two months three months maybe okay
so what if we hustled and we got five
grand in the next two months that gives
you eight grand in savings you take an
eight grand loan and uh with that extra
seven so leave a thousand in your
savings account we take seven we go buy
you a beater car
then you're out here yeah
that would that would work yeah they
won't work on paying off that small
eight thousand dollar loan you've got a
car to get you from A to B for a while
and you'll upgrade in no time once that
the rest of that debts paid off we
started saving up and we cash flow a
better vehicle
but the idea of you keeping this car and
paying it off it's just too much car for
your world man yeah that's what's your
car payment
uh it's pretty pricey it's a 760 oh I
know I know the reason I asked you that
is because I wanted you to say it I
wanted you to hear yourself say 760
because what George just walked you
through okay which seems like a headache
but it's actually not to do what he just
said and I'll be and I'll be very honest
with you uh because I've got three
teenagers one I just got a car for so
I'm always looking at cars I got two
more to get next year you can get a
decent car for Seven Grand you really
can it doesn't have to be a piece of
crap on Wheels but imagine 760 dollars a
month that you're paying for that car
gets reduced dramatically when you're
only paying off eight and You're Gonna
Knock that eight out pretty quick we're
talking about a real lifestyle change I
don't I don't want you to get lost in
the well I gotta go get a credit you
know a loan with a credit bureau and
then I got to do this and I gotta do
this you're changing your life
dramatically when that payment drops
tremendously do you feel that
right yeah I I do yeah how old are you
I'm 27. okay so what is 30 year old
Christian what does he want to do where
does he want to be financially three
years from now
well yeah that's kind of why I started
all this uh I've known about the Randy
sir for a while but I never really
started it it was just until I feel
myself kind of I'm done with this coming
I feel like I'm getting deeper into hold
and then more ahead I really do want to
be debt free and uh
uh really just a baseline to maybe get a
house sooner you know well I want you to
have that house stream front and center
but that's gonna be a while because
we've got to get rid of this debt we
have to get the emergency fund we have
to upgrade the car then we need to start
saving the down payment you're in Fresno
what is a normal what does a condo cost
in Fresno in your area
uh
not it's not too pricey about 300 300
000. that's it in Fresno that's shocking
to me
yeah it's not like in Fresno I live a
little bit out in the outskirts no
smaller neighborhood well I want you to
have that gold front center because at
27 years old you know the reason we get
this car is because we want to look good
we want to feel successful look
successful but instead we're sitting
here going I'm sending 800 bucks to A
lender with interest and I got 24
interest on these credit cards what am I
doing with my life I want 30 year old
Christian to be proud of what 27 year
old Christian did yeah and that's to
make these kinds of sacrifices
okay hey Christian check this out I was
just thinking while George was talking
to you when I was 27
I had been married uh for four years and
my wife and I were saving up for a house
and I was driving a cash car a Ford
Taurus that had no AC and I had to use a
staple gun to staple the roof uh film or
whatever the liner to keep it from
falling on my head at the stoplight you
know and I I wouldn't but I was but
listen man I was on purpose I was
focused on something way bigger than how
fancy my car was George Drive like no
one else so later you can drive like no
one else that's the key yeah I mean
what's important you know we got so many
people so many young people getting
sucked into the uh the look and feel of
certain things and these things tend to
depreciate they they tend to lose their
value just the emotional value as well
yeah that new car becomes used pretty
quick as soon as you drive it off the
lot so wishing you the best man thanks
for the call Blake's up next in D.C
Blake welcome to the show
hey guys thanks to uh sorry thanks for
taking my call sure um so we're on uh
step five or six
um I don't know how you look at it we're
saving for our son's college and uh the
only debt right now we have is uh two
mortgages so uh before we got married my
wife had a condo and uh now we live in a
townhouse so we have two mortgages on
those and then um we're starting to
outgrow our townhouse so we need to buy
a new house
um probably in the next two or three
years
um and we're trying to decide if we
should you know save up for a down
payment for the new house or try to pay
off these mortgages and um right now the
condo is a rental and uh the current
townhouse we would like to turn into a
rental
so you're wanting to keep both of these
and get a new house
yes oh boy then you're not gonna like my
advice
I don't think the answer to this is get
a third mortgage
which is what you're doing yeah
yeah I mean the I guess both of our
mortgage rates are like you know below
three percent which makes it hard to you
know sell and give up and
um
okay hold on let's just run some numbers
here okay so what is your uh mortgage
payment that you owe on the condo and
then how much are you uh profiting from
rent each month on just the condo
yeah so we're breaking even because my
in-laws are running the condo so that's
like 1600 a month in uh mortgage and and
rent okay so you're not making any money
on it so if one thing happens one repair
happens you're on the hole Yeah and this
is somehow a wealth building plan
because of an interest rate
what's the condo worth let's run those
numbers
if you sell it today give me a fair
price
I mean zillow's saying 330. yeah and why
are they not paying and how much do you
owe on it
um we owe like 190. okay
and what about the townhouse what's left
on that mortgage
um so that probably around like uh 450.
goodness all right what could it sell
for
uh
uh when I refinance last year is like
565 is what is the phrase at okay yeah
you don't have a lot of equity in these
properties and it all it takes is one
thing to go wrong one vacancy one HVAC
and you guys are screwed so I would be
selling this townhouse when you go to
move and honestly I'd probably look at
selling this condo too to get you guys
sell some good Financial spot you can
get an investment property later but pay
cash don't put yourself in the situation
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George camel
joined by Ken Coleman this hour if you
like this show we've got a lot more
where that came from on the Ramsey
Network my friend Ken Coleman hosts his
own show called The Ken Coleman show
right next door in the studio you can
check that out on YouTube podcast
Spotify wherever you get your content
and I've got a brand new YouTube channel
and it's also on Spotify video now did
you know that I was thinking that's
pretty cool so if you go on Spotify you
search George camel you can actually
watch him okay by the way thank you for
that don't help you out with that and by
the way he's the guy was made for
YouTube all right yeah watch my YouTube
videos and you go there's a middle-aged
dad you watch George on YouTube and you
go this guy that's a and out of touch
Millennial right there uh I'm telling
you it's hard it's hard to connect with
the youth these days because they think
I'm not cool older people don't think
I'm cool yeah so I'm a very specific
Target no I we're having a little fun at
our own expense there's good content on
both channels check it out that's true
but we're definitely not cool we can all
agree on that we know that all right
let's get to the phones Katrina's up
next in Charlotte North Carolina Katrina
welcome to the show
hi I'm really excited to talk to you
guys thank you guys for your help sure
what's going on
so I pursued a career uh in the past
that I felt was a good fit for me and I
was I remember me I mean I completed it
I got the certification and once I
completed school and I got in the career
I actually really didn't like it and
um so now I'm at I'm back to
ground one uh to the beginning and I'm
deciding to go back to school but I'm
honestly having a lot of fear I don't
know entirely what my major should be
and I just need guidance I need help I
wish I had that Clarity
um that I thought I had before but now I
feel like I'm I don't know I just that's
okay that's okay I I uh I want to dig
into this really quickly so what what
was the career path that you were in
that you that you regret going into what
was it
Tech and when you when you decided to go
into it what did you think it was going
to be or what were you excited about
that didn't pan out
is it clean with their physical health
physically mentally everything has that
changed
no no so you thought the surgical tech
was gonna you were gonna be a part of
their healing process and yeah and
exactly and then I started scrubbing in
and I'm standing there for 10 hour days
uh long cases and nobody's talking and
doctors were you know frustrated and I
was just getting anxious and I'm like oh
no this is not what I so I uh
there's a clue right there
you were in a surgical environment the
patient is under there's no interaction
with you and them and you probably had
to go check in on them do a little
research after the procedure just to see
if it helps so you didn't have any
connection to that human to see that
what you were doing or saying was making
them feel better or have some sort of
transformation hope towards a better
future do you see that
yeah so absolutely yeah because it felt
very technical it was the name but it
was yeah yeah so that tells me a lot
about you Katrina that you are all about
people work you're and I'm guessing you
have a lot of people skills is this true
or false
charge
but you know why that is I really do the
reason why is is because you give a lot
of energy to people and it's it's
similar to what George and I do I will
tell you that today already I hosted my
show I had about an eight minute break
and now I'm here with George we're doing
three hours here and then I got a
reception after this and where I'll be
talking to people and then I got an FPU
class I'll teach you later tonight and
later tonight I will just need to sit
there and read a book you know and
because why because I have given a lot
of my energy as it relates to my mind
and words and reading and Discerning
like I'm doing with you right now and so
when you are doing people work you will
feel depleted but you will also feel
rewarded does that make sense yeah and
you know I've I've considered even
nursing but I worked with nurses and
it's too stressful for me okay great I
know yeah but I so here's the deal I
think all right so now so I just wanted
to learn a little bit about you and see
what Clues we could figure out really
quickly now I'm going gonna put you on
the spot but I want you to not feel
pressure I want you to feel excited
because there's no right or wrong answer
are you ready to go
yeah all right she's ready
I think you have some ideas but you
don't have confidence that those ideas
are the right ones to pursue am I right
or wrong
yeah actually
so Katrina
think about the most real quick
well I really thought about becoming
like a Christian trauma therapist or
I've thought about becoming a physical
therapist yeah fantastic now let me tell
you why I love those two answers
the Christian trauma therapist so that's
in the emotional therapy the mental
therapy and then you got the physical
therapy and both of those Katrina allow
you to be people facing and that means
George that she's going to be looking
people in the eye she's going to be
communicating with people in order to
find out what's hurting whether that be
in their soul or in their body and then
you're going to come up with a plan and
work with them they've got to work with
you in both of those jobs there is a
give and take yes
yeah I'm actually already getting like
excited I could hear you smiling I could
hear the smile yeah and so yeah so let
me just say this that those are two
ideas that to me I believe that God has
wired you for I believe you have the
talent to to win in those fields I
believe you have the passion which means
you love the work itself and I think
that you care deeply about the results
so you're going to be motivated to meet
people in their place of pain and help
them with transformation to get over the
pain so that's how we ideate and we come
up with ideas there and then we can go
we don't choose a major first in fact we
don't even think about school unless we
look at both of those and we go is a
degree required for both of those the
answer is yes so now we do have some
schooling
um okay yeah but the process for you and
I'm going to give you my get clear
assessment which I think is going to be
very confirming for you and it measures
Talent what you do best passion the work
you love to do and then Mission which is
a term that I use for what motivates me
if you can get answers to those three
things and that assessment will do that
if you answer it honestly I think it's
gonna it will spit out a purpose
statement that ends up being a high
level job description and I think it
will confirm both of those two ideas but
I think you you just needed confidence
young lady that what you were thinking
and feeling made sense yeah George yeah
as Christina was talking I was going she
doesn't trust herself because she felt
like she flubbed it with this career
path and now she can't trust herself
again and that's not what happened you
nailed it you just narrowed down exactly
what you wanted to do and you're super
young how old are you
I'm 26. most people don't even figure
this out until they're in their 40s or
50s and they have so much regret yeah
you have your whole life ahead of you I
agree so the next question is and as you
were talking I said physical therapist I
think that's exactly right for her and
you were spot on so what's the next step
for school have you looked into how much
that's going to cost and how you're
going to cash flow it
actually I
I work for an Amazon distribution center
and they actually pitch in for
um costs as well they do so I'm I might
be able to carry come on four years
incredible free or or really close to
free
um I am still trying to pay off the debt
that I had from the previous
certification so how much you got left
I I have eighteen thousand dollars from
student loans and then I have ten
thousand dollars from credit cards and
medical bills which is the Ten Thousand
is just you know life circumstances but
the student loans is 18K and I was
actually going to ask if I should pay
all that off before starting school
Katrina I was just getting ready to say
are you willing to do what it takes and
you were going to say
yes I did and I was going to ask you are
you willing to wait as long as it takes
that's a different question and uh we
want you paying that debt off first how
much do you make
well right now it's um it's like 35k a
year which is not my
agreement to make 80 to 100K a year oh
you'll get there because don't worry I'm
not worried about that but let's get our
income up so we can knock this dead out
fast so that we can cash flow this
schooling so that we can get to that
dream you're gonna get there in no time
because you know exactly what you're
after now what an inspiring call we're
cheering you on that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
yeah
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show for we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by my dear dear friend
Mr Ken Coleman this hour and we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's the
number to call if you want to jump in
the conversation two deers two deers
just a dear friend you went with the
dear dear friend I thought it was
appropriate oh I feel so loved right now
Jordan that was my goal all right well I
got some people to help if you want to
spread the love and you like this show
please consider subscribing leave a
review share it with a friend we've seen
the data Ken that is how this show grows
it's not through fancy marketing and
paid advertising it's from people like
you going hey you gotta check out this
episode it really helped me get out of
debt it gave me some hope it gave me
some motivation so we so appreciate all
of you who have left those reviews
subscribe to our channels and share it
with people
yeah my new tagline is be a bro share
the show what do you think about that I
don't like it I don't want to shop but
it's got a whole lot of Velveeta on it
and I don't like it I don't like I tell
you what I do like is when people call
in going hey I'm I'm stuck I'm scared
I'm confused whether it be in their
money life their work life so we're
taking those calls this hour George Will
straighten you out on those baby steps
of the money and if if your work
situation I'm making enough income or uh
you're just not happy where you are but
you're worried about a loss of income
work and money issues go hand in hand so
we're here for you this hour good word
inextricably thank you that's a good
word can't always us my vocab when I'm
hanging that's what we do we make each
other better George all right let's get
to the phones Lee kicks us off in
Columbus Ohio Lee welcome to the show
sure um
um my husband and I are on baby step
three
um we decided to upgrade his car because
we are expecting our first baby in
December
and
I am just wondering where you draw the
line with cost sunk fallacy we made the
decision pretty quick we didn't mind
putting a little bit of money into it
but we sold his car which was a two-door
standard shift which I don't know how to
drive and wanted something that was a
little bit more family friendly
um so we upgraded to a four-door and of
course we didn't
you know cross our T's dot our eyes and
get it checked out by mechanic and we're
about 3 000 men and now the
transmission's making a sound so we're
like we're when do we cut our losses and
you know we ouch baby step three but
we're we're on track to have our five to
six month savings by the time the baby
comes so we didn't mind cash flowing a
little bit but yeah because we're kind
of drawing the line have you looked into
what the repair is going to cost
we just put in
about so these were not unforeseen like
new tires shocks brake pads all that
okay my husband could do some of the
work but the sound that's coming out now
might be like a crack in the
transmission so that could be as
something as simple as a patch he'll get
as far lifted on Monday and then it
could be you know real bad like a new
transmission we just wanted to kind of
be prepared for that worst case scenario
mentally
what do you think you could sell it for
right now even with the potential
transmission issue
um
we got got it for about 11. we could
probably sell it for about nine or ten
oh wow as is all the work put into it
yeah
and that's assuming a crack so obviously
if it needs a new transmission and it's
going to go like that obviously wouldn't
be honest I do the homework to figure
out I would too before we catastrophize
and go we gotta go get a brand new car
because we got a baby let's figure out
if this is a thousand dollar fix or a
five thousand dollar fix and then go are
we gonna Roi on this so if we put 5000
in is it going to increase the value to
14 or 15 maybe not we'll have to see and
what car could we get for a similar
amount and if you can't get that much
car for what you'd be paying into it it
may be worth just keeping even if you do
the repair yeah but I would absolutely
look into the transmission get two if
you do you have a trusted mechanic that
you know they're going to tell you the
truth you got some history with this
oh for sure yeah there it's a guy that
goes to our church okay I would research
it with him what's the real problem
what's the real fix and just to give you
an idea several years ago I sold a car
my transmission was starting to go and I
listed it that way I said look here's
the deal it's still running it'll get
you from point A to B but you are going
to need to place replace the
transmission and this is what the quote
is on this and I I reduced the price
probably by about three grand less than
what and I still got cash for it yeah
and so to me it was a win I didn't put
any money in it and I still came out of
course with some cash so I would look at
all those situations and then it just
comes down to what's the right amount of
amount of spin for you whether it's to
fix uh or to get something different I
think your common sense is going to win
the day
thank you yeah we're just feeling a bit
of stupid tax with uh we could have just
he had a perfectly fine car we just and
I have a good car and you know building
up our emergency fund if his car were to
go and we do keep it it's not a true
emergency we can be a one-car family for
a second oh great good yeah get creative
with it you know what I I appreciate the
emotion you're feeling right now but we
need to let yourself off the hook there
on the stupid tax it is what it is
you're in good shape now this is not a
crisis absolutely and if you want to
take if you want to sell it for 10K and
go get you something and inspect it with
your mechanic before you buy that's what
I would do you feel better about yes
that's okay you'll never make this
there's no wrong way to do this the only
wrong way is to go into debt out of fear
and paranoia that you know the car is
going to burn up on the interstate
once you have this oh yeah so that's
what most people say
I'm proud of you guys you're very
level-headed about this whole discussion
and can we take calls about cars all the
time and it grinds our gears pun
intended sometimes because people go
well Ken there's no safe cars under ten
thousand dollars so I need to go get a
forty thousand dollar brand new car with
a loan so I can be a good parent and
protect my family right that's a
ridiculous treatment yeah there's
unreliable cars just because they have
even a hundred thousand miles on them
listen if if all those people who live
in this day and age could go back to the
80s when I was growing up and look at
the car that my mom and dad drove me
around with no seat belt in the front it
was their forearm it's gonna be okay and
you went uphill both ways yeah I mean
that's impressive but you know it's
honestly it's like you could go get a
decent Minivan and if it gets you from
point A to point B who cares what it
looks like yes and I know that the car
market right now is insane so if you're
looking to get a car especially a new
car or a used car the prices are crazy
are you seeing though that they're
dropping a little little bit we're
starting to see a little bit but there's
still so many weird variables involved
in the car market right now that I would
just try to get a car that's as
affordable as possible to get you from
point A to point B now is not the time
to flex and unless you're a millionaire
do not go buy a new car you simply
cannot afford the hit on depreciation
it's just too much of your world wrapped
up in something going down in value so
if you want to pay cash for a reasonable
used car and all of the things with
wheels and Motors in it in your life add
up to less than half of your income
that's how you know you're not out of
control it's a great parameter to help
me go is this crazy to spend this much
yeah it is because I make 40 Grand and
my car is worth 30. that is insane by
the way if you're buying a car on the
open market from someone else not a
dealer and even the dealers they can be
sketchy but ask to take it to your
mechanic yes that makes them nervous run
you need to be nervous if they say no
you can't take this to mechanic walk
away yeah go find a dealership who will
allow you to do that because that's
going to give you the piece of Minds no
you're not buying a lemon you're not
going to have seventeen thousand dollars
in repairs which is how people
catastrophize this stuff in their minds
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour this is the Ramsey
Show
and call us up at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you want to
talk about your life your work your
money our question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services if you're moving you've
got a long list of to Do's but
neighborly has got local Pros like house
Master five star painting and Junk King
to check those items off the list visit
neighborly.com today to schedule Home
Service Experts near you today's
question comes from Daniel in Maryland
I'm starting the application process for
college however I'm in a dilemma my
dream school is George Washington
University in DC and the tuition costs
oh
oh thousand dollars a year hello
including room and board
the total would be 320
I'm a well-rounded student he's talking
about four years I'm a well-rounded
student who can get into the school but
I have a higher chance to get in if I do
early decision as you probably know this
is binding and I won't know the amount
of Merit I will be getting before I get
accepted no I just want to stop before
we get to the rest of the question this
is stacked against these young people
it's a game this is like this is this is
Cia level stuff sad and scary should I
apply early
or should I do a regular decision to see
what money I get but sacrifice the
higher chance of getting in well I think
this is the wrong question completely
but I'll answer the question
um if it were if you were my son and you
asked me this and I'd say look I would
do the regular decision to see what kind
of money you can get it's not that
important I would certainly not do the
early decision just for the chance of a
higher percentage of getting accepted
because I know you're excited about
George Washington University and I'm a
Virginian and so I know of that's a it's
a it's a fine institution George it's
got a lot of prestige but no one and I
mean no one cares especially George
Washington you know you know that guy's
not paying 320 Grand yeah he go to his
own school yeah so he thinks it's a scam
too exactly so you know your parents
don't care they're going to be proud of
you no matter where you go to school
your eventual customers or clients when
did it begin about the college when did
it not become about hey I got the
education get this job versus I went to
this school the short answer is in the
60s when when we begin to see the
federal student loan program get up and
going and it then it was a marketing
message that going to four-year
University you're going to get more
education which means you're going to
get a better job parents believe that
and the system supported that that was
true at the time that is less and less
true in 2023 but that's when it became a
status symbol when it was the you know
our friend Mike Rowe he talks about the
poster that he saw he's made this poster
famous
um he's in the he's in high school in
the 70s and his guidance counselors
talking about where to go to college and
over his head is a is a poster a split
you know screen if you will where it
says uh work smart and it shows the
white collar college graduate he's got
his white collars Ty he's got his
diploma he's got his cap and gown and
he's got a dentine smile ding and then
on the other side where it says work
smart not hard it's got a dude with
grease on his face a wrench that could
kill a horse and you know a scowl on his
face and it's poo pooing the trades
going you don't want to be like this guy
yeah but the subliminal message is if
you go to college you're going to be
successful and have great looking they
got the photo up on the screen there it
is thank you guys you're watching on
YouTube look at this if you're watching
this the message to millions of
Americans is don't work hard go to
college instead and do white collar work
because you'll be more successful
everything about it just says and so you
want to know when College became a
status symbol that's when it became a
status symbol but I got to tell you
those days are over yeah nobody cares
and I remember being in Daniel's shoes
because I got into my dream School Ken
it was Emerson College in Boston I was
gonna go to film and media great school
impressive and it was 50 Grand a year
and I got no help I got no financial
assistance parents hadn't saved for
college and even back then not knowing
Dave I went uh 200 grand for a film
degree sounds like a terrible idea yeah
and so I didn't do it I ended up going
to a state school for a little while and
uh it was the best decision I made to
not go 200 Grand into debt and that's
what I feel for Daniel regardless of
what career choice is going to go into
to start off your adult life 300 Grand
in the hole is no way to live and by the
way let's let's just bury this okay
because the cultural argument is well
the ROI is there I would say the ROI
isn't there and people argue with me oh
whatever well let's just run it out okay
you can't look at it as a straight 320
000 versus what you're going to make in
the totality of your career what you
have to look at it is is that most of
these kids aren't paying this debt off
George you know the data how many years
has it taken most people to pay off
student loans 20 years 20 years so it's
320 000 Baseline and then the 20 years
of interest payments and still sort of
half a million so it does not Roi as it
relates to to the first five to seven
years of your career and certainly not
when it comes to your emotional and
mental health you're stunted in all
categories and the schools are genius
for scamming everyone into going we will
accept you the opportunity to be
accepted and you can have the
opportunity to pay us eighty thousand
dollars a year yeah it's literally a
privilege it's atrocious it's literally
going thank you thank you for the
opportunity to go three hundred twenty
thousand dollars in debt and if you want
more on this we've got a free
documentary that you can go watch called
borrowed future on YouTube watch this if
you're a parent if you're a teen if
you're in college it will show you the
truth about this entire student loan
industry and higher education in general
good stuff there all right let's go to
McKenna in Springfield Missouri McKenna
welcome to the show
hi thank you so much
sure what's going on
um so I'll be as brief as possible my
husband and I are on baby step four five
and six we have followed Dave Ramsey
since before we were even married and we
have had a really really hard year and a
half we've had three job changes we've
lived in three different homes we've had
medical diagnoses cars die we've used
our emergency fund more than we ever
have and we just were struggling to find
the motivation and we're just frustrated
like how how do we have no money and how
are we not getting anywhere and I just I
wondered if you had any advice or
feeling defeated and see stuff well this
is much emotional and mental as it is
financial and so I'll speak to the
finance part real quick obviously baby
step four five six they happen
simultaneously you have 15 going to
retirement we're putting a little bit
away for college and we're putting
whatever's left onto the house so
clearly you guys have been in a season
where you haven't been able to do a
whole lot of that because life has just
been coming at you and that's okay
the key here is you've been able to
cover all of this and it hasn't become a
crisis it's just been an inconvenience
and it feels like this is going to
happen forever but the truth is it's
just a crazy season yeah
yeah right
you got to hang in there it's tough but
I can just tell you you guys have been
in a prolonged storm of life where a lot
of stuff has hit you and yet here you
are on the phone today I hear a little
one in the background everybody's okay
you know we're still here we're making
it we haven't quit and I think you got
to hold on to that because when you look
back on this many years from now and you
stay the course
and you don't accept debt as an
opportunity to make some of this storm
go away or make it feel better you're
gonna look back on this and and see the
growth that that came from this time and
I think you just have to keep your head
down and keep going through it I've told
this story before when we did our our
live stream back in the middle of covet
I told the uh the story it's not a story
it's just the reality of the difference
between a buffalo and a cow uh they're
they're cousins but When Storms Come at
cows out on the field they run away from
the storm and the storm inevitably
catches up with them and they end up
running with the storm so they stay in
it longer but Buffalo for whatever
reason they see a storm out on the
planes and they run into the storm full
speed and they get through the storm
faster and I think right now it's just
stay with the principles the baby stuff
stay with it you know get that emergency
fund built back up hang in there don't
quit moving forward and I think the
storm will pass and that's the
encouragement I want you to hold on to
because uh you're stronger today than
you were a year ago when all this stuff
started happening to you and you guys
have lived to tell about it and you're
gonna get through this I promise
give yourselves Grace McKenna this is a
process and you've moved out of baby
step two and three which means you we've
we've moved from intense to intentional
and so I found what helps me when in
these seasons is turning to gratitude
and contentment and going thank God we
had that emergency fund where would we
be today without that thank God we had
good health insurance to cover that Matt
thank God we had good car insurance to
cover that repair all of those things
help you look to the Future instead of
paying for the past and so we're
cheering you on through four and six it
may be longer than you want it to be but
you're still in an incredible place
[Music]
oh
hey if you're financially ready to buy
your first home in this market it is not
because of luck it's because you've been
putting in the work and kicking butt at
budgeting and saving and we're so
excited for you and we don't want your
hard work to go to waste buying a house
is the biggest purchase you will ever
make and the last thing you need to do
is fly solo or work with some garbage
real estate agent even if it's your Aunt
Susan and she's a very nice lady you
can't leave this up to an agent who's
just good enough you need great and a
Ramsay trusted agent is a great agent
they set you up for Success before and
after closing day by helping you find
the ride home keeping you on track with
your goals and making sure you're
confident in your decision Ramsay
trusted Pros get our stamp of approval
because we know they work hard to serve
you not to pad their paycheck
so you've worked too hard to buy your
first home with anyone but the best you
can find a Ramsay trusted real estate
agent by going to ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramseysolutions.com agent
Corey joins us up next in Norfolk
Virginia Corey what's going on
hey how you guys doing good how are you
real quick I have a
I have a debt of 20 000 less left on a
vehicle okay
um with the baby steps I've been able to
knock out all the credit card debt and
I'm just down to this zero interest
payment on this car
um but I still owe 20 000 on it I have
depending on the day in the market
roughly eight thousand to seven thousand
dollars worth of stocks okay
um what I've been doing is they're
dividend stocks and I've enrolling the
dividends into the payment however
um I haven't really been happy with the
performance of the stocks and I was just
wondering do I take those stocks just
sell them and
throw them down on the payment
or keep them hold them and kind of save
them for the later steps
in the baby steps since I already have
them I don't
I'm just kind of confused on what would
be the best course we'll take out all
the confusion here I would sell the
stocks today and make sure you account
for any taxes that you'll have on those
gains and I tell you that with
confidence because I was in your exact
shoes when I started this plan I had
worked at the Apple Store I had some
stocks and I had about the same amount
you did about seven thousand eight
thousand or so and I cashed it out to
knock out my student loan debt and help
me become debt free faster
okay so anything that's non-retirement
we would tell you that even if it was
mutual funds and a brokerage account
that was non-retirement I would tell you
to cash it out and stocks are even
scarier because of the volatility with
them being in single companies and so I
would I'd get off this train before it
crashes for sure
and it's going to speed that's gonna
knock out almost half your debt so how
much faster is that going to speed up
the process for you
uh I've been budgeting and um
our monthly income is around it's five
thousand two hundred and thirty six
dollars
we got our expenses down to last month
was three thousand seven hundred dollars
cool um including the minimum payment
and we've been just rolling anything
extra into so you got like 1500 bucks
extra to throw at this debt
yes sir uh so basically the car is going
to be paid off if we if I don't do
anything and continue the Way I Am by my
math roughly uh 16 18 months and this
will speed that up to like eight or ten
months probably right
yes I love that man that makes me feel
yes sir I mean you can see the light at
the end of the tunnel as soon as these
stocks are paid off and I would
absolutely do it and I and I did it so I
don't tell you this is someone who
wouldn't do the same we're cheering you
on man thanks for the call Tammy is in
Tampa Tammy and Tampa I like that what's
going on Tammy
hey thanks for taking my call
um I'm selling selling my house and I
expect to net about 145 000 from that
and I plan on putting about 75 000 down
on a condo which will leave me with a
seventy thousand dollar mortgage
um I'm gonna after I pay off my debts
and tithe on the income that I received
from the house the sale of the house
we're gonna have about thirty thousand
dollars left and I'm not sure what I
should do with that
why not put it towards the new home
um it's not going to be a forever home
it's going to be uh I'm gonna live there
until I'm no longer working home and
then I'm going to sell it that's okay I
mean why put anything into the home at
that point if it's not a forever home
um
I have to find a place to live in Tampa
this area is hard right now for rent
you're looking at Seventeen hundred
dollars for a one bedroom apartment I
understand I'm saying that Equity is not
going to disappear if you put that 30k
into the new home
it will give you a smaller mortgage that
you'll pay off faster and a lower
monthly payment
and so it'll alleviate a whole lot of
stress and help you become totally debt
free I mean what if you could own that
house free and clear to where when you
sold that thing it was all profit
wouldn't that be cool
well I know because this is interesting
you just laid out for us that with the
money you want to put down you'll owe 70
on the condo but if you do what George
told you to do and you put that 30 on it
now you're only going to owe 40 am I
right
that is correct start looking at those
numbers
look at how much less you're paying per
month it's not a huge amount but still
you're paying less per month and you're
going to be able to pay off the 40
really quickly now all of a sudden you
have no household expenses as it relates
to mortgage just your just your
utilities and all that and so you're
sitting really pretty and you got
yourself a real solid investment in
Tampa Florida which is one of the by the
way all real estate in Florida right now
I just read this week is hot
yeah my house sold in one day yeah so
why not why not put the 30 is what we're
saying why not go and put the remaining
30 on the condo
I'm gonna
I'm gonna look at everything again good
I love it okay and as long as you're
still investing 15 towards retirement
and you're on track there I want to see
you have a paid for house because then
how much could you invest at that point
twenty percent thirty percent forty
percent fifty percent
wouldn't that be amazing
and so I just there's nothing like
having a paid for house and sometimes
the math doesn't reflect that on paper
and people like love to argue with us
about well I have a three percent
interest rate why would I pay off my
mortgage I don't know freedom
not just freeing up the payment but
emotionally mentally spiritually the
options it gives you to give save spend
differently there's nothing like it
Tammy and you're on your way
alrighty I can't believe that my
automatic default was to say yes
to the mortgage more of a mortgage well
that's that's how we're wired the
message you've been given
but this is a whole different ball game
this speeds up your retirement plan as
it relates to being completely free
financially this is a great move for you
I love this and Ken this was a this is a
big thing that people grapple with when
it comes to the Ramsay plan is paying
off the house early and just doing the
house the right way we recommend a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay that sounds insane in
today's world he'll go they're out of
touch with reality Ken no we just want
you to not be broke forever and be house
poor and that might mean you need to
increase your income that might mean you
need to pause for two years and save up
a bigger down payment well there's a
question you have to be patient to take
that strategy of a 15-year fixed well
that goes you got to put more the
payments higher on a 15 year and I'm
going a lower payment just means you're
even more broke because you're paying
more in interest right since when is a
low payment the goal walk into a car
dealership and say I love as low of
payment as possible they're happy to
give it to you and that's how you know
you're getting screwed yeah they'll
finance a car for 37 years if if they
were allowed to exactly so yeah I agree
but people didn't understand that that
15-year that that means a bigger down
payment that means you got to save up
more money longer it takes more time but
what it's going to do is just save you
time on the back end because you're
paying off that house so much faster in
Financial Freedom Equity everything's
better and when you don't have a house
payment you could I don't know retire
with dignity and you could work because
you want to and not because you have to
that's a very different mentality than
we're seeing in today's world Ken where
people are going I'm 67 and I'm still
working a job I hate because we still
have the mortgage hanging around our
next yeah it's absolutely right and so
it's very freeing to follow these steps
get out of debt get the emergency fund
invest 15 save some for college start
paying off the house early and when you
do that you're at baby step seven The
Mountaintop where you get to build
wealth and give outrageously and there's
nothing like it let me tell you who's
almost there with a bright and sunny
future who Tammy from Tampa oh my gosh I
that threw me for curveball can that was
pretty good I had to bring it back I
love it well we're cheering all of you
on that are in that step attacking that
home there's nothing like it you step in
that grass and it's all yours baby even
if there's some patches in it this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
21 21. whoever pursues righteousness and
love finds life prosperity and honor
Ralph Waldo Emerson said life is a
succession of lessons which must be
lived to be understood
okay guys got away with words uh let me
tell you something Ralph Waldo Emerson
has got some of the all-time gold quotes
one of the all-time best Ralphs that I
can think of
I mean certainly above Ralph Macchio
that's about the only other one I know
so that's that's where it ends love it
are we leaving out any other famous
Ralph's guy Ralph uh wasn't there a car
uh uh wasn't there a uh um
that's from the deep dark dark base of
my brain when the kids were watching
cartoons all the time in those movies
you forget it was a different era for
you Ken yeah glad to be past that all
right well let's get to the phones
Krista joins us up next in Asheville
North Carolina Krista welcome to the
show
thank you thank you for taking my call
yeah
I'm pulling in because I signed up for
FPU almost a year ago in August but I'm
Paralyzed by progressing through the
baby step
and the reason I am is because my
husband and I own a small business which
is significantly less profitable than it
has been in past years we've been in
business since 1993
um but it's just not in a good state
right now what kind of business one of
the things I'm trying to identify is
opportunities for me to change my career
um for more steady income
and also
um because I'm I'm really I was never
really interested in the companies so to
speak but I
um have been working there to support my
husband and why he wanted so it's his
dream and you were kind of going along
with it to help make a reality that's
exactly what I've been saying can he do
it without you I I think the answer is
yes but if you leave to go get something
that you enjoy that you make much better
money what would that what kind of
situation would that put him in
well the business is doing so poorly and
my contribution is usually doing the
books and um
so things like that so it sounds like
he'd be thrilled if you went and got a
really good paying job that you loved
well
the answer is no because he's like I'd
like to think that we can work together
and get through this well he doesn't
want to face the reality that this
business may not be it anymore
correct what kind of business is it
it is an I.T or and Telecommunications
Company can we agree that it and Telecom
has changed drastically over 30 years
well you and I do but he still believes
that you know Hardware is where it's at
is this going to cause a massive
relational issue if and I'm saying this
hypothetically you told him this evening
hey I can't do this anymore here's why I
want us to get out of debt I need more
income to help us do that I've never
enjoyed this this thing is stressful
and lay it all out for him and say I
want your support on this is that going
to cause a massive problem
well I doubt it because I've said it
before but I haven't given the reasons
of getting out of debt and if that and
the other although I mentioned it and
he's like that's when he said I'd like
to think that we can work together and
we're just the two of us you got to have
a heart to heart here
we got several issues going on in this
question the first is you got to have a
heart to heart with him and he needs to
relationally let you go on this decision
and go all right you're my wife first
and foremost not my business partner
first and foremost and I think that has
to happen first then the next thing is
is you've got to just say all right what
is it that I want to do what is it that
I can do based on my existing talent and
experience if there's some skills that I
got to pick up you know how can I get
qualified for those what's the you know
the most effective way to do that and
and get after it you know but right now
for you guys where you're at to get
started on the baby steps because I'm
bringing it all back to your paralyzed
you've got some fear of getting serious
about the baby steps and and I I'm gonna
challenge you on that in a second and
I'm going to hand it to George but
right now let's say that you're not
quite sure what that white collar or
that next big career move is the reality
is is you can go make pretty good money
probably more money than he's paying you
just doing something that doesn't
require any kind of qualifications it's
just maybe customer service related
you're working for a big box store or
whatever uh you know or manufacturing or
you're doing anything making twenty
dollars an hour and a customer service
role or or or or some type of sales job
that again is trained as you go so I
want to paint a picture for you that
more income is sitting there waiting for
you just to move towards it then the big
picture if you want to make eighty
hundred thousand you want to go some
career direction or whatever that's a
different ball game but there's a fear
in you
that shouldn't exist because of going
through the baby steps is going to
actually relieve the financial tension
George absolutely so what is the
household income right now I'm guessing
the net profits of the business
well yeah I mean last year it was the
goodness
yeah I think here's what I would do if I
was in your shoes I would say hey
husband we have to set a goal and if
this business can't get back up to you
know a hundred thousand a year in the
next six or so months then we have to
re-look at this thing and maybe you go
get an I.T job because you have 30 years
experience in it and you can make double
or triple that I can go do bookkeeping I
can make double what I'm making and all
of a sudden this becomes a very
different picture
yeah but again this starts with that
conversation I've even tried to Pivot
the company
um but his response is only I'm a
hardware guy yeah so you know what I'm
just gonna keep it real I I I wouldn't
wait six months
okay I wouldn't wait six hours the
conversation happens tonight
he's listen he's your husband and you
trying to talk him out of this it
doesn't sound like it's gonna happen at
all what you need is more income when he
starts seeing the influx of income that
you're bringing and he starts going look
my wife is leading me into with this
whole financial peace process uh we'll
he'll come along for the ride but right
now there's no convincing him doesn't
make any sense to me to stay doing what
you're doing
no and I agree and I mean I because of
the financial State and me not having a
job that I enjoy
um you know it's hard for me to you know
be happy in myself so I I listen I
understand it's going to turn into
resentment and it probably already has
that you've been doing this for 30 years
and you didn't even want to do it
right
so we have to have this conversation
flexibility when the kids were little
and I understand that value and I mean I
did my my dad was very sick and ended up
passing away
um I do take care of my mom still so all
that thing all of that those items
create
um
a need for flexibility so to speak well
he's hanging on to the past and we need
to be very concerned about the future
because you guys need to retire someday
do you have any debt right now
oh yeah we have
a lot sold our home
High
and the income just wasn't in here to
scrape to keep the house our mortgage
was
um
only like twenty five hundred dollars
but then we had an equity line that made
it almost four thousand dollars how much
debt do you have now and with our income
only down you know
25 of what we were accustomed to
um something had to give
so we did sell the house we did pay down
some of our debt we have the rest of the
equity from the house in a bank
um so Krista what's left on the debt
um
let's see we've got about 30 000 in
credit cards oh my gosh and another 30
000 in medical bills
um actually about 35 000 in medical
bills
and
um we've got one car
that we owe about 35 000 on it was worth
about 50. Bad Thing needs to get sold
I'd sell that tomorrow and you just sit
down with them you're the bookkeeper
you're the numbers gal sit down with
them show them the numbers show them the
interest rate the amortization schedules
and frighten him to death and tell him I
am so scared I can't breathe and I can't
sleep because I know we're never gonna
be able to retire we're headed towards
bankruptcy at this point something's got
to change and it's not about you and
your dreams and your business this is
about us surviving and being able to
retire one day and that's going to be a
real tough situation Krista I'm sorry
you guys are going through this but
there's no good way no pretty ending to
this go get you a 20 an hour job I don't
even care what it is that's a massive
raise over what the two of you did last
year so let's go get busy gotta work
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books my thanks to Ken Coleman
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show float and new America will be back
with you before you know it foreign
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]